a suburb underwater
part of the australian city of sydney
inundated amid warnings that could be
worse to come
we are now facing dangers on multiple
fronts
flash flooding riverine flooding and
coastal erosion
in just one day the sydney area
experienced four times the amount of
rain it normally receives during the
whole month of july
sports fields have turned into lakes and
forecasters expect heavy rainfall to
intensify over the coming days
this is a life-threatening emergency
situation
the city's reservoirs are already full
the waragamba dam beginning to overflow
well ahead of predictions
the level of the dams there's no room
for the water to to remain in the dams
they are starting to spill the rivers
are flowing very fast and very dangerous
and then we have the risk of flash
flooding depending on where the rains
are so there's a lot of risk out there
that our community needs to be aware of
and i ask you to heed the warnings
powerful winds have blended this seafoam
across north carolina beach into a car
park nearby
locals say the beach has been washed
away
and not recovered from erosion in
previous storms
australia has the world's highest
greenhouse gas emissions from coal
but it's also the front frontline of
climate change experiencing more extreme
droughts and bushfires and major storms
flooding in march killed 20 people there
have been 2000 calls for help after the
latest deluge
are warning the situation is constantly
evolving and dangerous
barbara anger al jazeera